[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
monday july 25th i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
last week u.s law enforcement announced
it had disrupted a north korean
state-sponsored hacking campaign that
targeted hospitals and other medical
facilities here in the u.s
the justice department said it was able
to claw back half a million dollars
worth of cryptocurrency for a kansas
medical facility that was targeted by
the hackers and identify a new type of
malware that was used
it's part of a new strategy by the biden
administration to stop state-sponsored
hackers we should note north korea has
denied it targets other countries with
cyber attacks and the north korean
mission to the united nations didn't
respond to a request for comment
for more on this specific attack and the
government's changing approach to
defending against cyber attacks we're
joined by our cyber security reporter
dustin volts hey dustin thanks for being
here thanks so much for having me
okay so let's start with why north korea
would support this kind of ransomware
attack so north korea has been a major
cyber security threat for many years
against the us and other western nations
really you know anybody in the world
that they think they can hack and and
make a buck from so you know whereas
russia and china and iran maybe have you
know sort of more uh geopolitical or
espionage oriented goals with their
hacking north korea for a number of
years now has shown that they
are desperate to make money through
their hacking and the reason for that is
because of course they are under an
enormous set of sanctions
due to their nuclear weapons program
that they continue to develop and so
hacking whether it's you know crypto
mining whether it's ransomware attacks
all sorts of different manners of sort
of malicious cyber activity it is a way
for them to evade the sanctions that
have been levied against them for a
number of years and continue to support
the regime and in some cases fund
directly their nuclear weapons program
how are authorities in this case able to
track and stop this attack
so this was yet another example of
authorities at the justice department in
the fbi working to you know follow the
money essentially but follow the money
on the blockchain and you know this was
another case where cryptocurrency was
used to pay the hackers and you know
there's sort of this mindset that i
think has been pervasive throughout the
digital currency community for a number
of years that basically all payments are
anonymous you can't really track people
but in fact the blockchain by nature
records every single transaction and
despite the you know often best efforts
of the bad guys law enforcement has
shown by partnering with a number of
cyber security firms that specialize in
cryptocurrency tracking that they can in
fact sort of find
and identify
who is getting paid the ransoms the fbi
and other agencies have shown several
times now over the past many months that
they they can use a variety of forensic
investigative techniques to sometimes
track these guys down some of those
techniques to be honest are not always
fully clear in court records or not
clearly stated exactly how they did it
because you know you can imagine that
there are certain tools that the u.s
intelligence agencies are using to sort
of help out in investigating some of
these hacks but you know the capacity is
there for
investigators to
follow the money on the blockchain and
in some cases work to
seize funds that are left in you know a
digital currency wallet in this case
that's what happened here the heck of
the kansas medical facility brought in
help from law enforcement and they were
able to claw back about a half a million
dollars and what's not clear is you know
how much was not clawed back it's not
totally clear that this was the entirety
of the payment in this specific hack and
it's also not clear
you know how much money the north korean
hackers were able to ransom in other
cases and still have access to
right and while i'm sure the kansas
facility is is pleased to have its money
returned to it at least some of it there
is this bigger question of what happens
to the people behind the attack you know
if there's from north korea if it's a
state-sponsored attack how would the u.s
hold these people accountable and i
guess that goes for other foreign
hackers as well does the us have to
change its strategy when it comes to
tracking these people down so this is
always a problem when we talk about
prosecuting hacking cases particularly
nation state cases where
you know you're talking about people in
saint petersburg or tehran or pyongyang
who are maybe never going to travel the
united states and are not going to face
an american courtroom this is not a new
phenomenon you know occasionally some of
these hackers might travel or vacation
to you know some island somewhere or you
know the coast of spain and then local
authorities will nab them and then turn
them over to the united states and so
there's always a possibility of that but
really you know i think there's a
recognition in the biodemonstration and
certainly in this justice department
under deputy attorney lisa monaco who
announced the results of their case here
and the seizure of the money with the
kansas medical facility there's a
recognition that that doesn't doesn't
really cut it and so you know a big part
of the strategy that miss monaco has
articulated over you know weeks and
months now is that we want to basically
do what we did for counter-terrorism
after september 11th which is you know
thwart the bad activity before it
happens or if it is happening to
diminish the overall
amount of damage that can be done
has the justice department or deputy
attorney general lisa monaco explained
what they mean by they're treating it
like fighting terrorism because you know
you don't necessarily know about a cyber
attack until it's happening and apart
from telling companies to boost their
cyber security is there anything
authorities can do ahead of these
attacks there are things that you know
the nsa and and u.s cyber command
working in tandem again with the fbi and
others
there are things that they do where they
are you know able to sort of get an idea
of what
hackers whether they're in north korea
or somewhere else what they intend to do
before they do it and you know there's
something that general paul nakasoni who
leads the national security agency talks
about all the time which is defend ford
and it's really the idea of
using offensive capabilities of you know
surveillance uh hacking into networks of
the bad guys abroad and using
intelligence gleaned from that to
understand you know what they're doing
who they're harming and what they might
do next
and increasingly you're sort of seeing
a push to use that intelligence not to
you know understand what's going on but
to you know sort of prevent the next
attack to minimize the next attack to
educate the public and businesses and so
forth about you know specific threats
that they should be vigilant about and
steps that they can take to potentially
minimize it in addition to in some cases
maybe
taking servers offline that the hackers
are using especially if they
are you know located in a place where we
might have an allied government that
wants to help us with that
all right that's our reporter dustin
volts thanks so much for joining us
again dustin thank you and that's it for
today's tech news briefing if you want
more tech stories check out our website
wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you